well here's to the young wolf who
Forever Young hey youtubers it's Charlie
so I just wanted to try something a
little bit different today and just do a
little bit of a vlog so I can do a lot
of things that I didn't get to include
in my videos earlier this week or I
won't be able to include in videos later
this week so I'll also be uploading a
divergent preview that'll look just like
my normal videos so but I thought I'd
try out this format too so you can let
me know you think of it but first things
first let's talk about the new actor on
Game of Thrones season 4 so Michael
who's Finn has been cast in season four
at Game of Thrones and a lot of people
think he's going to be a new character
but there are reports that he's just
replacing a character on the show
and that could be joseph molly he
actually played Benjen stark in season 1
and if you remember in the books that
character basically just disappears and
we never see him again
up to the point where we are now and
dance with dragons but it also looks
like he could be a number of other
characters too so let me know you think
I don't think that he's going to be a
Greyjoy I just did a video for the
Greyjoy's I'll have a link to that at
the end of the video that you can see
because I think that the new actor is
actually going to be Mark Gatiss for one
of the Greyjoy actors if who spend is
replacing the Benjen stark character
then what is that character doing in
season 4 that'll be really interesting
because in book 5 you actually meet cold
hands and technically a lot of people
think that that character is someone
else and they don't think it's Benjen
stark but the show could mess with the
story just a little bit so we'll find
out
speaking of casting remember Star Wars
Episode 7 is going to be filming in
January just like the Warcraft movie but
there have been some casting rumors for
the Skywalker children including Alex
Pettyfer for a possible Luke Skywalker
son that's not really confirmed but I
think it's really interesting and Rachel
Hurd would who could be one of the solo
children but since the movie is filming
in January they're gonna have to lock
this cast down really soon so I think
whoever it ends up being and whoever
knew these actors they had to picking
are we're gonna find out in the next
month or two so back to TV so a lot of
you were asking me questions about
supernatural in my arrow season to
preview which is kind of funny and even
though I didn't recap the show last year
a lot of you made the request so I will
be doing supernatural videos when that
comes back to then that's in the
beginning of October so get rid of
excited the show is going into season 9
but it hasn't quite got a season 10 yet
but everyone kind of expects it to
happen just because Smallville actually
admittedly being pretty terrible made it
to season 10 so if that can happen then
supernatural which is way more popular
can definitely make it to ten seasons
but this season they just announced
they're going to be doing a big Wizard
of Oz storyline and Felicia Day is
coming back the suddenly the Oz episode
we'll deal with the men of letters and
we'll take place in the 1930s and the
Dorothy character in The Wizard of Oz
story will basically be like a hunter
the showrunners were a little bit vague
but they did say that season 9 is going
to largely deal with a lot of the
mythology that they haven't had a chance
to deal with before to so get really
excited if you get really deep into the
demon mythology of the show then season
9 is gonna be really exciting for you so
a couple things that I did not get to
include in my ear' season 2 preview so
it looks like Amanda Waller is going to
be on the show you remember she was
played by Pam Grier on Smallville and
there's no indication that she's going
to reprise that role but it does look
like they're going to include the
Suicide Squad this is the DC and Warner
Brothers give them a lot of latitude
with the characters they use in the show
so they get to use a lot more of the DC
Universe then shows in the past tab
Smallville actually had a big problem
with that and they kind of had to mess
with characters a little bit just
because DC was so protective but I think
because the arrow has been so well
received and so popular they've kind of
opened up a little bit so we got Suicide
Squad Amanda Waller and a lot more cool
stuff more TV news so just give me an
idea what's going on in my life in the
next week or so I've got a big
announcement that I'm going to tease but
before that Futurama is actually doing
this big finale event at the YouTube
space it's gonna be hosted by Chris
Hardwick of Nerdist so I'm really
excited to meet them but the show has
had a really good run so I think there's
gonna be a little bit bittersweet but
I'm trying to shoot some video there I
don't know if I'll be allowed to film it
but it should be a lot of fun so I'll
try to do some vlogging there in another
news I'm planning to do a bunch of
orphan black coverage next year but in
the meantime Tatiana maslany is actually
gonna be on Parks and Recreation there's
actually there's really awesome pictures
that Amy Poehler posted it is really
really funny so I'm really expecting
this to be really awesome episode
because Parks and Rec is just killing it
right now they have so many extra guest
characters coming I'll do a video for
that Parks and Rec episode when it comes
but I'll be doing regular orphan black
videos when that comes back next year so
look forward to that be sure to
subscribe to get all those videos I've
also got a divergent preview coming
later today hopefully it'll be ready in
time to post with this video too so
you'd be able to watch them both but
I've also got my Game of Thrones video
series that I'm working on too that will
probably come starting on Monday that
will actually be just to give you
idea just based on each character and
it'll deal mostly with what's going on
in season four specific to certain
characters so it'll be really exciting
look just at specific characters in each
different video let me know which
characters you're most excited about in
season four and I'll try to post those
videos first so if you really want to
help me up please like and share this
video and let me know what you think
about this vlog format I know it looks a
little bit different from my normal
videos don't worry I'll be doing other
videos that'll look like my normal
videos these videos are kind of really
just intended to collect news that
doesn't fit into my other videos and
just be like a blog format just so I can
answer your questions so in the meantime
you can click here to get that divergent
preview and you can click here to catch
that arrow season 2 preview if you
didn't see it yesterday thanks so much
for watching see you guys tomorrow
you